Now that we've seen an alternative
way of representing polynomials,
let's turn back to the problem
of multiplying them.
Multiplying via the convolution equation
takes order nm time, as we've seen.
If the polynomials are represented as
values, however, we can just multiply
the corresponding values to
obtain the values of the product.
Note that I did have to start with
a number of points that was equal to
the order of the product here.
Not the order of the polynomials
that we were multiplying.
The fact that multiplying in the value
representation is so much faster
than in the coefficient representation
suggests that it might make sense
to convert to the value representation,
do the multiplication there, and
then interpolate back to
the coefficient representation.
We'll visualize the process like this.
First we convert from
the coefficient representation
to the value representation.
Then we multiply the corresponding
values to get the values of the product
polynomial, C.
And then we interpolate back to get the
coefficients of the product polynomial.